Tyra: "AMERICA'S NEXT
TOP MODEL"
IS ABOUT DREAMS,
PLAIN AND SIMPLE.
AND IT'S ABOUT ACCOMPLISHING
THESE DREAMS THROUGH
HARD WORK, TALENT AND PASSION.
I WORKED MY BUTT OFFf
TO GET TO THE TOP
OF THE MODELING INDUSTRY,
SO I KNOW EXACTLY
WHAT IT TAKES TO MAKE A STAR.
LAST SEASON ADRIANNE CURRY
WENT FROM WAITRESS TO TOP MODEL
NOW IN DEMAND BY REVLON,
HIGH-PROFILE MAGAZINES
AND TOP DESIGNERS.
BUT THIS BUSINESS MOVES FAST,
AND FASHION WAITS FOR NO ONE.
AFTER A NATIONWIDE SEARCH,
I DISCOVERED 12 FRESH FACES
FROM ALL ACROSS THE COUNTRY--
A BEAUTIFUL MIX OF STYLES,
ETHNICITIES AND FIGURES
FROM EDGY TO WAIF
TO PLUS SIZE TO PETITE.
AND EACH AND EVERY SINGLE ONE
OF THOSE GIRLS
FEELS LIKE THEY HAVE "IT."
♪♪♪
>> Tyra: THE 12 FINALISTS
FROM ALL OVER THE COUNTRY
ARE ABOUT TO MEET
FOR THE FIRST TIME
ON THE MEAN STREETS
OF MANHATTAN.
BUT WHICH ONE HAS WHAT IT TAKES
TO BE AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL?
WE'RE ABOUT TO FIND OUT.
Anna: COULD YOU TELL ME
WHERE BROAD STREET IS?
Xiomara: HEY,
WHAT'S YOUR NAME?
Catie: CATIE.
WHAT'S YOURS?
Xiomara: XIOMARA.
Anna: HELLO!
Xiomara: WHAT UP?
Anna: I'M ANNA.
Xiomara: XIOMARA.
NICE TO MEET YOU.
Anna: GOOD TO MEET YOU.
Catie: CATIE.
Anna: CATIE, I'M ANNA.
GOOD TO MEET YOU.
Catie: IS THAT FOR US?
Xiomara: THE BUS PULLS UP,
AND IT'S THIS TOTAL
ROCK STAR BUS.
Catie: OH, MY GOODNESS.
Xiomara: AMAZING LIGHTS
ALL OVER, PLUSH LEATHER COUCHES.
WHOO!
THIS IS THE...
THE STUFF.
Anna: AAH!
Xiomara: AND WE DON'T KNOW
WHERE WE'RE GOING.
Anna: YOU KNOW,
I LEFT MY HUSBAND AND MY SON.
Xiomara: HOLY CRAP!
ARE YOU KIDDING ME?
YOUR HUSBAND AND YOUR SON?
HOW OLD IS YOUR SON?
Anna: HE'S 2, 2 YEARS OLD.
Xiomara: AW, BAMBINO!
Anna: I AM A MOTHER.
I AM A WIFE,
AND IT'S HARD
BEING AWAY FROM THEM,
BUT I DON'T LOOK
AT HAVING A FAMILY BEING
A HINDRANCE TO MY CAREER.
Catie: WHAT DOES YOUR HUSBAND
THINK OF YOU BEING HERE?
Anna: OH,
HE SUPPORTS ME 100%.
Xiomara: OH, THAT'S GREAT.
Catie: THE BUS PICKS UP
MORE GIRLS
AS THE TIME GOES ON.
April: YOU GUYS ARE ARRIVING
IN STYLE.
Catie: AS THEY
WERE GETTING ON,
I WAS THINKING, WOW,
WHAT A GROUP OF BEAUTIFUL GIRLS.
April: YOU'RE ONLY 18?
Catie: YEAH, I GRADUATED
FROM HIGH SCHOOL EARLY
TO MOVE OUT TO L.A.
April: TO...?
Catie: PURSUE MODELING.
I WANT TO BE A MODEL,
BECAUSE I LIKE TO BE
THE CENTER OF ATTENTION.
AND THAT'S WHY I GAVE UP
THE LAST HALF OF MY SENIOR YEAR.
COLLEGE WILL BE THERE
AND MODELING WON'T.
April: OH, SO THIS IS...
YOU'RE ALL ABOUT THIS.
Catie: YEAH,
THIS IS WHAT I'M DOING.
April: SEE, THIS IS
SUCH A DERAIL FOR MY LIFE.
BEFORE COMING HERE,
I WAS WORKING
FOR A FORTUNE 500 COMPANY
MANAGING CORPORATE
BUSINESS ACCOUNTS,
BUT THAT WASN'T ENOUGH FOR ME,
SO I'M READY TO EXPLORE
THAT OTHER SIDE OF MYSELF,
BUT I NEVER THOUGHT
THAT THIS WAS GONNA HAPPEN.
I JUST DID IT FOR FUN, YOU KNOW?
SO WE'LL SEE.
Camille: WHAT MADE YOU
WANT TO MODEL?
Yoanna: I HAVE ALWAYS
WANTED TO, BUT THEN I WAS
A LITTLE CHUBBY,
SO I GOT A TRAINER
AND I LOST 50 POUNDS.
I WANTED TO START MODELING,
AND THE MARKET THAT I WANTED
TO BE IN WAS HIGH FASHION,
AND I KNOW I COULDN'T FIT
INTO THE CLOTHES
THAT THE DESIGNERS WOULD WANT
IF I WAS THE SIZE
THAT I USED TO BE.
Woman: WOW!
Woman #2: VERY GOOD.
Xiomara: YOU GO!
THAT'S AWESOME.
MY FIRST IMPRESSION
IS THAT I'M VERY, VERY
DIFFERENT FROM THESE GIRLS.
PEOPLE DIDN'T REALLY LOOK AT ME
OR TAKE NOTICE TO ME.
I WAS ALWAYS DIFFERENT-LOOKING.
I WANNA BE AN ALTERNATIVE TYPE
OF IMAGE TO WIN.
I THINK I COULD DO THAT.
Bethany: MY NAME IS BETHANY.
I CAN OBVIOUSLY
DO SWIMSUITS.
THAT'S WHAT SOME PEOPLE WANNA
PUT ME IN THAT CATEGORY,
'CAUSE I'M BLONDE
AND HAVE BIGGER BOOBS,
BUT I HAVE A LOT MORE TALENT
THAN THE BOOBS.
♪♪♪
Shandi: MY NAME IS SHANDI.
I WORK AT A WALGREENS.
I'M A SERVICE CLERK.
I WAS NEVER TOLD THAT I WAS
PRETTY OR ANYTHING.
I WAS, LIKE,
THIS LITTLE MOUSY,
NERDY GIRL.
IT'S JUST BEEN, LIKE,
OVER THE PAST COUPLE YEARS
THAT I'VE BEEN, LIKE, TRYING
TO WEAR, LIKE, GIRLIE THINGS,
WEARING MAKEUP MORE.
IT'LL BE NICE TO FEEL A LITTLE
BIT BETTER ABOUT MYSELF.
Sara: HI.
Shandi: HI.
Sara: ARE YOU HERE...
Bethany: WHAT'S YOUR NAME?
Shandi: SHANDI.
Bethany: SHANDI? BETH.
Shandi: BETH.
Sara: I'M SARA.
WHAT'S YOUR NAME AGAIN?
Shandi: SHANDI.
SHANDI--
I DON'T KNOW. I JUST--
EVEN THOUGH SHE'S VERY TALL
AND THIN, I JUST DON'T SEE IT.
HER EYES ARE VERY CLOSE
TOGETHER.
SHE KINDA
REMINDS ME OF A BIRD.
I DON'T SEE HER MAKING IT.
HI!
Woman: HELLO!
Woman #2: HI, GIRLS.
April: WE GOT SOME
FRESH BLOOD IN THE HOUSE.
I'M AWESTRUCK
BY SARA'S BEAUTY.
FROM THE FIRST MOMENT I SEE HER,
HER PRESENCE--IT'S SO SEXY.
HER FACE IS SO EXOTIC.
Sara: I'M HALF PERSIAN.
MY DAD'S IRANIAN.
MY MOM'S AMERICAN.
AND MY FATHER WAS SO NOT
SUPPORTIVE OF THIS INDUSTRY.
HE CONSIDERS THIS PROSTITUTION.
MODELING HAS JUST BEEN MY DREAM,
AND I'M NOT GONNA LET SOMEBODY
TEAR THAT DOWN.
I THINK, LIKE, MAYBE
MY BIGGEST ACCOMPLISHMENT--
I WAS MISS JAMAICA U.S.
FIRST RUNNER-UP.
WHAT'S GONNA DIFFERENTIATE ME
FROM ALL THOSE OTHER GIRLS
IS THE FACT THAT
I CAN DO IT BETTER.
I DID SOME PAGEANTS,
LIKE MISS FLORIDA.
I WAS FIFTH PLACE.
BUT, UM, I'VE DONE A LOT OF,
LIKE, FASHION SHOWS,
LIKE RUNWAY SHOWS
AND SOME PRINT WORK
WHEN I WAS A LOT YOUNGER,
BUT I HAVE
A MAJOR IN ADVERTISING
AND MINOR IN FASHION.
Bethany: I DON'T KNOW
ALL ABOUT THESE PEOPLE,
BUT I'M GONNA GO AHEAD
AND MAKE A JUDGMENT ANYWAY.
(laughs)
CAMILLE--SHE'S VERY FAKE.
Camille: I CAN HELP
YOU GUYS OUT.
IT'S GREAT.
Sara: I CAN TELL THAT
CAMILLE'S GONNA BE SOMEBODY
THAT'S GONNA CAUSE
A LOT OF PROBLEMS.
I THINK SHE JUST REALLY BELIEVES
THAT SHE'S THE... THE STUFF.
Jenascia: LOOK,
A BLACK AND WHITE BUS.
Mercedes: HEY!
♪♪♪
Woman: HI!
Woman #2: HEY.
Heather: I'M HEATHER.
I'M STILL YOUNG.
I'M STILL,
YOU KNOW, FRESH FISH.
I CAN STILL GET OUT THERE
AND PURSUE THIS LONGER
THAN THEY CAN.
SO I'LL DO ANYTHING IN MY POWER
TO WIN.
Jenascia: I'M JENASCIA.
Woman: JENASCIA?
Woman #2: JENASCIA?
Jenascia: I'M LOOKING,
AND USUALLY WHEN YOU'RE
IN A COMPETITION,
YOU CAN KIND OF
ASSESS, LIKE, OKAY,
I CAN PROBABLY BEAT THAT PERSON,
AND I NOTICED THAT I AM
THE SHORTEST GIRL,
AND I WAS THINKING, THAT,
YOU KNOW, I'D JUST WEAR HEELS
THE ENTIRE TIME I'M HERE,
BUT...
(bleep) IT.
Mercedes: I'M MERCEDES.
Xiomara: MERCEDES!
April: WHERE ARE YOU FROM
ORIGINALLY?
Mercedes: I'M ORIGINALLY
FROM JERSEY, BUT I LIVE
IN VALENCIA, CALIFORNIA.
GROWING UP IN JERSEY,
I WAS THE RUDEST GIRL EVER.
I WOULD GET INTO FIGHTS.
MOVING TO VALENCIA, CALIFORNIA--
IT WAS A GOOD NEIGHBORHOOD,
AND I THINK THAT CHANGE
INFLUENCED ME TO JUST BE
A BETTER PERSON.
IT'S BEEN A CRAZY TURN
OF EVENTS.
Jenascia: GOING TO
THE HOUSE NOW?
Xiomara: WE'RE HOPING SO.
Yoanna: I THINK WE WERE
ALL EXCITED AND NERVOUS
AND WE WERE TRYING TO GUESTIMATE
WHAT'S GONNA HAPPEN NEXT.
♪♪♪
Jenascia: OH,
YOU GOTTA BE KIDDING ME.
Bethany: BOOT CAMP.
Shandi: SOLDIERS?
Sara: I LOVE THEM.
Catie: YOU LIKE SOLDIERS?
Mercedes: WHEN WE GET OFF
THE BUS, I SEE TWO COLONELS,
AND I'M THINKING, OH, GOD,
PLEASE DON'T BE
MILITARY TRAINING.
Officer: ON BEHALF OF
THE UNITED STATES MARINE CORPS,
I WOULD LIKE TO WELCOME YOU
TO NEW YORK CITY.
NOW BEHIND YOU
YOU SEE THE "U.S.S. INTREPID."
IT SAW A LOT OF ACTION
DURING WORLD WAR II.
IT WAS AN ACTIVE DUTY
AIRCRAFT CARRIER.
BUT YOU'RE PROBABLY WONDERING
WHY YOU'RE HERE.
PLEASE FOLLOW ME.
Xiomara: (laughing)
Heather: ARE WE GONNA LIVE
ON A SHIP?
ARE YOU SERIOUS?
Jenascia: I HAVE NO IDEA
WHAT WAS GOING ON.
I'M LIKE, WHAT THE HELL
ARE WE DOING HERE?
I HOPE IT HAS SOMETHING TO DO
WITH FOOD, 'CAUSE I'M STARVING.
♪♪♪
♪ YEAH ♪
♪ UH-HUH... ♪♪
Sara: THIS DOESN'T SEEM
LIKE REALITY, YOU KNOW?
TYRA BANKS,
SUPERMODEL OF THE WORLD,
IS RIGHT IN FRONT OF ME.
Tyra: ALL RIGHTY.
YOU GUYS ARE THE FINAL 12,
AND I WANNA CONGRATULATE
YOU GUYS FOR GETTING THIS FAR.
THIS IS MY BOY--
THE DIVA EXTRAORDINAIRE,
THE UNDEFEATED CHAMPION
OF THE RUNWAY--
MR. J. ALEXANDER.
J.: HEY, GIRLS.
Yoanna: I KNEW ABOUT J.
HE HAS TAUGHT SOME
OF THE BEST GIRLS,
LIKE, IN THIS INDUSTRY.
♪♪♪
J.: MY MOTTO IS
WALK LIKE IT'S FOR SALE
AND THE RENT IS DUE TONIGHT.
Tyra: I'M NOT WASTING
ANY TIME.
I'M THROWING YOU
STRAIGHT ON A RUNWAY.
NO TRAININ', NO NOTHIN'.
I WANNA SEE
WHAT YOU GOT.
AND YOU GUYS AREN'T GONNA BE
DOING THIS FASHION SHOW IN FRONT
OF STUFFY FASHION FOLKS.
YOU'RE GONNA BE DOING IT
IN FRONT OF THE BEST
OF NEW YORK--OUR FIREFIGHTERS
AND OUR MILITARY.
Shandi: I'M THINKING,
OH, MY GOD.
I'M JUST THROWN INTO EVERYTHING.
Tyra: AND YOU'LL BE GETTING
YOUR WALK ON TO THE BEATS
OF FUNKMASTER FLEX.
NOW REMEMBER, YOU GUYS,
THIS IS REAL.
THIS IS A COMPETITION,
ALL RIGHT?
Camille: HEY,
IT'S A COMPETITION.
IT'S MY TIME. I'M READY.
LET'S GO. LET'S DO THIS.
Tyra: SO GOOD LUCK,
AND I'M GONNA BE WATCHING YOU.
Jenascia: ARE YOU KIDDING ME?
♪♪♪
Jenascia: GET TO
THE "INTREPID,"
AND THEN THERE'S TYRA,
LOOKING ALL GLAMOROUS,
"HEY, GUYS,
WE'RE GONNA DO A FASHION SHOW."
SO WE'RE NOT GETTING ANY FOOD?
Xiomara: I HAVE NEVER DONE
RUNWAY WALKING BEFORE.
J.: FOLLOW ME, GIRLS.
RIGHT OVER HERE.
April: WE WERE ABOUT TO DO
A RUNWAY SHOW FOR THE MARINES.
I ALWAYS WANNA BE NUMBER ONE
AT ANYTHING I TRY TO DO.
J.: SO WHAT YOU GIRLS DIDN'T
KNOW WAS THAT YOU HAVE DO
YOUR OWN HAIR
AND YOUR OWN MAKEUP.
AFTER THAT, YOU'LL FIND
THE RACK HERE WITH YOUR NAME
AND YOUR CLOTHING.
AND YOU EACH WILL BE WEARING
THREE OUTFITS.
IT'S VERY, VERY CRITICAL
THAT YOU REMEMBER YOUR ORDER.
YOU HAVE 30 MINUTES
FROM THIS POINT ON.
TICK-TOCK, TICK-TOCK.
SO LET'S GO.
ALL RIGHT, REMEMBER,
FOLLOW THE HAIR AND MAKEUP
INSTRUCTIONS IN FRONT OF YOU
AT THE MAKEUP AND HAIR TABLE.
Catie: THERE ARE SIGNS HERE
THAT TELL US WHAT WE NEED TO DO,
AND WE HAVE TO DO IT
IN 30 MINUTES.
J.: HURRY UP. 20 MINUTES.
Shandi: I AM REALLY
NERVE-RACKED RIGHT NOW.
EVERYTHING IS RUSH,
RUSH, RUSH, RUSH, RUSH.
GET DONE, GET YOUR HAIR,
YOUR MAKEUP, YOUR CLOTHES ON.
I DID NOT EXPECT THIS.
J.: YOUR AUDIENCE IS GETTING
QUITE RESTLESS,
WAITING FOR YOU OUTSIDE.
Bethany: I'VE WALKED
A RUNWAY BEFORE,
JUST NOT LIKE THIS.
J.: TICK-TOCK, TICK-TOCK.
PRESSURE IS ON.
HURRY UP.
April: I HAVE
THE WRONG OUTFIT ON.
Jenascia: ALL OF A SUDDEN,
I SAW THAT APRIL, LIKE, DIDN'T
HAVE HER (bleep) TOGETHER,
AND SHE HAD HER SECOND OUTFIT ON
FIRST.
April: THEY'RE LOOKING FOR
ANY REASON TO ELIMINATE US.
AND I START TO CRY IMMEDIATELY
BECAUSE I AM SO STRESSED
THAT I MANAGE TO SCREW UP
WITHIN THE FIRST TEN MINUTES
OF THIS COMPETITION.
Jenascia: HERE, I'LL DO THAT,
YOU DO THIS.
April: THE ONLY THING THAT IS
LITERALLY KEEPING MY KNEES FROM
COLLAPSING ON ME RIGHT NOW--
THE FACT THAT JENASCIA
IS AT MY SIDE.
EVERY INCH OF ME EMOTIONALLY
IS LEANING UP AGAINST
THIS LITTLE 5'6" GIRL.
Jenascia: DON'T CRY.
WHATEVER YOU DO, DON'T CRY.
April: I'M THINKING,
I OWE HER.
Jenascia: I'M NOT REALLY
THAT NICE OF A PERSON.
I DON'T KNOW WHAT'S
COME OVER ME.
♪♪♪
Heather: I'VE NEVER WALKED
A RUNWAY BEFORE IN MY LIFE.
I DON'T KNOW WHAT TO DO.
I'M JUST WALKING LIKE I THINK
A MODEL SHOULD WALK LIKE.
April: THE ADRENALINE
IS PUMPING, AND EVERYTHING
THAT HAS JUST HAPPENED
IN THE DRESSING ROOM
IS LEFT BEHIND.
Anna: THEY JUST KINDA PUT US
OUT THERE, BUT NOT REALLY
ANY TRAINING.
IT WAS CRAZY, BUT IT WAS
ALSO REALLY FUN.
Tyra: THERE'S A LOT OF
MISTAKES THAT ROOKIE MODELS MAKE
ON THE RUNWAY.
SOME GIRLS HAVE NEVER WALKED
IN HEELS, SO THEY LOOK
ABSOLUTELY RIDICULOUS
WITH THEIR KNEES BENT
AND JUST WOBBLIN'.
Shandi: I'M LOOKING
AT THESE HEELS, THESE BOOTS.
I'M THINKING, "OH, GOODNESS.
I BETTER NOT FALL."
Tyra: A LOT OF THEM THINK,
"OH, I'M JUST SO SEXY.
I CAN JUST STRUT,
AND I'M JUST SO SEXIFIED."
Camille: I WENT OUT THERE
AND I DID MY THING.
MY WALK WAS VERY CALM,
YOU KNOW, YET SEXY.
Tyra: SUPER WRONG.
SOME GIRLS GET TO THE END
OF THE RUNWAY AND FEEL LIKE
THEY HAVE TO STRIKE TEN POSES
AS IF THEY'RE DOING
A PHOTO SHOOT,
AND SOME GIRLS HAVE NO IDEA
WHAT THEY ARE DOING AT ALL.
♪♪♪
Tyra: ALL RIGHT. IT'S OVER.
Shandi: AFTER
THE FASHION SHOW WAS OVER WITH
AND ALL THE RUNWAY THINGS
WERE DONE, AND WE'RE JUST--
I'M JUST THINKING,
"THANK YOU, GOD."
J.: OKAY, GIRLS,
SO THAT WAS YOUR FIRST
FASHION EXPERIENCE.
PERSONALLY, I THINK
YOU ALL SUCKED, ACTUALLY.
April: I'M THINKING
HE'S TALKING TO ME.
I'M THINKING I WANNA CALL MY MOM
AND I'M THINKING I'M A FAILURE.
J.: I JUST SEE THINGS
THAT JUST NEED TO BE REDONE.
YOU GIRLS HAVE TO BE
OPEN FOR THAT CHANGE.
Jenascia: THERE WAS SOME
DIFFICULT STUFF, THOUGH,
LIKE, WITH ALL THE BUTTONS
AND BELTS AND STRAPS
AND THE SHOES--OH, MY.
J.: OKAY, GIRLS, SO HERE'S THE
KEY TO YOUR NEW HOME.
Women: (shouting over
each other)
♪♪♪
Camille: WHOO! WE'RE IN!
Jenascia: LADIES,
WE HAVE MAIL.
"WELCOME TO
YOUR NEW CRIB.
GOT TO THE FOURTH FLOOR.
IT'S A BLING-BLING,
PUNK-FUNK,
MOD KIND OF
WORLD UP IN HERE.
STAKE YOUR CLAIM. TYRA."
Women: WHOO!
♪♪♪
Yoanna: LOOK AT
THE FURNITURE!
Shandi: COME LOOK
AT THIS PLACE.
Bethany: LOOK
AT THE BEDROOM!
Yoanna: AAH!
Catie: I BET TWO
HAVE TO SLEEP THERE.
♪♪♪
Xiomara: WHOO!
(laughing)
♪♪♪
Yoanna: THIS IS MY BUNK
RIGHT HERE.
Jenascia: YOU SEE THIS?
YOU SEE THIS?
Sara: OH, MY GOD.
THE PLACE IS JUST CRAZY.
THE RUNWAY IN THE MIDDLE,
THE HARDWOOD FLOORS.
I LOVE IT!
Jenascia: GOOD JOB, JENASCIA.
GOOD JOB.
Yoanna: WELL, I DON'T KNOW
ABOUT CLIMBING.
THE HOUSE IS SO AMAZING.
I LOVE THE COLOR SCHEME
AND THE ART.
I WANTED TO TOUCH THE CANVASES,
BUT I ALSO DON'T WANNA BE LIABLE
FOR BREAKING OR DAMAGING
ANYTHING.
SORRY.
Catie: I NEVER THOUGHT I
WOULD LIVE IN A PLACE LIKE THIS.
IT'S SURREAL.
Mercedes: WE'RE JUST HAVING
A GOOD TIME IN THE HOUSE
AND JUST TRYING TO FIGURE OUT
WHO EVERYBODY REALLY IS.
Jenascia: OKAY, THIS IS
WHAT I THINK ABOUT THE ROOMS--
THERE IS GONNA BE CERTAIN PEOPLE
THAT WANT CERTAIN ROOMS
THAT MAYBE OTHER PEOPLE DON'T,
SO THERE'LL BE NO CONTEST.
April: FOR THE PEOPLE
WHO HAVE A PREFERENCE,
SAY WHAT YOUR PREFERENCE IS.
EVERYONE WHO DOESN'T CARE
WILL JUST GRAB WHAT'S LEFT.
Xiomara: IT'S A PULLOUT BED,
AND I THINK THAT WE SHOULD
ROTATE THAT PULLOUT BED.
Camille: I SPECIFICALLY SAID
THAT I DON'T WANNA SLEEP
ON A SLEEPOUT 'CAUSE NORMALLY,
LIKE, THE MATTRESS
IS REALLY THIN,
AND IT HURTS YOUR BACK.
IT'S JUST THE WAY I WORK,
'CAUSE I CAN'T DEAL.
Sara: I'M SITTING BACK,
AND I WAS JUST THINKING THAT
I'M GONNA BE LIVING WITH
A BUNCH OF HIGH-MAINTENANCE
DRAMA QUEENS.
'CAUSE THAT'S WHAT GIRLS ARE--
HIGH-MAINTENANCE DRAMA QUEENS.
(laughs)
Catie: OH, MY GOODNESS.
SHE'S ALREADY CLEANIN'.
WHAT A GOOD MOMMY.
ANNA--SHE'S SO SWEET.
I THINK IT'S INSPIRING TO KNOW
THAT JUST BECAUSE YOU HAVE
A HUSBAND OR YOU HAVE A CHILD,
DOESN'T MEAN THAT YOU NEED
TO PUT YOUR DREAMS ON HOLD.
Anna: WHEN I LOOK AT
THE OTHER GIRLS AND MYSELF,
YOU KNOW, DEFINITELY WE'RE ON
DIFFERENT LEVELS.
I AM A MOTHER. I AM A WIFE.
Xiomara: I LOOK UP TO YOU,
JUST SO FAR, LIKE FOR, LIKE,
EVERYTHING THAT YOU'VE DONE.
IT'S UPLIFTING TO SEE THAT
SHE'S STILL DOING HER THING.
SHE'S STILL LOOKING FOR
A DREAM.
YOU'RE MY MAMA. (laughing)
Anna: COME HERE.
Xiomara: AW.
Anna: I KNEW THAT I WOULD BE
AWAY FROM MY FAMILY FOR AWHILE
DURING THIS PROCESS.
ME AND MY HUSBAND HAVE
TALKED ABOUT IT.
YOU KNOW, I'VE TRIED TO GET
MY SON TO UNDERSTAND.
Anna's son: Hi, Mama!
Anna: HEY, MAKARIOUS.
Makarious: I miss you, Mama.
Anna: OH, THAT'S SO SWEET.
I LOVE YOU.
Makarious: I love you.
Anna: (whispering)
GOOD NIGHT.
Woman: GOOD NIGHT.
♪♪♪
Tyra: HI, EVERYBODY.
Anna: GOOD MORNING!
Tyra: GOOD MORNING.
Shandi: I SEE TYRA COMING IN
TOWARDS THE LIVING ROOM.
I'M THINKING, "OH, NO.
WHAT'S GONNA HAPPEN?
WHAT'S SHE GONNA SAY
TO ALL OF US?"
Tyra: WELL, I JUST WANNA
LET YOU GUYS ALL KNOW
THAT I HAND-SELECTED
EVERY SINGLE ONE OF YOU.
EVERYBODY'S DIFFERENT,
AND HAS
THEIR OWN PERSONAL STYLE,
PERSONAL FEATURES,
AND I JUST
WANNA SAY, Y'ALL FLY.
Women: (laughing)
Anna: WHAT'S, LIKE,
THE MOST IMPORTANT THING,
LIKE, WORDS OF WISDOM
ABOUT THIS INDUSTRY?
Tyra: YOU NEED TO LIVE,
BREATHE AND EAT THIS.
THIS NEEDS TO BE YOUR LIFE.
I NEED YOU GUYS TO WANT THIS
SO BAD, THAT IF IT
DOESN'T HAPPEN, YOU HAVE TO GO,
"OH, MY GOD.
WHAT AM I GONNA DO
WITH MY LIFE NOW?"
THAT'S THE TYPE OF DEDICATION
THAT I NEED FROM EACH
AND EVERY SINGLE ONE OF YOU.
EVERY WEEK ONE
OF YOU GUYS
IS GONNA GO HOME.
EVERY WEEK SOMEBODY'S GONNA BE
HEARTBROKEN, AND THERE'S ONLY
GONNA BE ONE PERSON REMAINING.
BUT I HAVE LOVE
FOR EVERY SINGLE ONE OF YOU,
SO I WANNA PASS SOMETHING OUT
FOR EVERYBODY.
I DESIGNED THESE MYSELF
JUST FOR Y'ALL.
Women: OH, MY GOD!
April: WHAT'S MOST BEAUTIFUL
ABOUT THIS GIFT
IS WHAT IT REPRESENTS.
WOW, TYRA BANKS SEES SOMETHING
IN ME THAT'S WORTH SOMETHING?
MY GOD. THAT'S AMAZING.
Shandi: FOR MY EYES TO GET
KINDA WATERY JUST KINDA
SURPRISED ME
AND I'M THINKING, "WOW,
I'M REALLY DOING THIS."
Tyra: COME ON.
LOVE, LOVE,
LOVE, LOVE, LOVE.
Mercedes: TYRA IS MAKING ME
WANT THIS COMPETITION EVEN MORE.
Women: AW!
♪♪♪
Xiomara: (haughty voice)
TONIGHT WE'RE HAVING DINNER
AT THE TAVERN ON THE GREEN.
Camille: TAVERN ON THE GREEN
IS A FABULOUS RESTAURANT,
AND IT TAKES A VERY LONG TIME
TO GET A RESERVATION THERE.
(dishes clatter)
April: OH, SHOOT.
Women: (laughing)
April: I DON'T KNOW
WHAT YOU'RE SAYING.
Bethany: WE HAVE
NO TOILET PAPER IN THERE?
Sara: WE HAVE PAPER TOWELS.
Yoanna: BUT THEY DO HERE.
I'LL BE RIGHT BACK.
Women: NO!
Camille: YOU DON'T GO TO
A VERY EXPENSIVE,
CLASSY RESTAURANT AND STEAL
TOILET PAPER.
IT'S EMBARRASSING.
Yoanna: PRESENT!
Catie: I FEEL LIKE THOSE
OLD LADIES WHO, LIKE, TAKE
THE SALT/PEPPER SHAKERS
AND STUFF.
Camille: I WAS KINDA
DISAPPOINTED IN SEEING HOW
THE GIRLS CONDUCTED THEMSELVES.
DON'T PUT YOUR ELBOWS
ON THE TABLE, OR YOU DON'T
TAKE UP AN ENTIRE PIECE OF BREAD
AND PUT, LIKE, FIVE THINGS
OF BUTTER IN IT, AND, LIKE,
SHOVE THE WHOLE THING
IN YOUR MOUTH.
MAYBE I'M JUST A LITTLE BIT MORE
EDUCATED THAN SOME
OF THE OTHER GIRLS.
April: THANK YOU. TYRA MAIL.
"HEY, LADIES.
IT'S YOUR BIRTHDAY.
YOU'RE GONNA WORK THE LENS
LIKE IT'S YOUR FIRST DAY..."
Xiomara: YES!
April: "BE READY AT 6 A.M.
FOR YOUR FIRST PHOTO SHOOT."
Xiomara: THANK YOU,
THANK YOU.
April: I HAVE NO CLUE
WHAT TO EXPECT.
I DON'T KNOW IF I'M GONNA HAVE
TO BE WEARING A THONG
OR AN EVENING GOWN OR WHAT.
I WILL TOTALLY MAKE SURE
THAT I WAKE EVERY SINGLE ONE
OF YOU UP.
Jenascia: APRIL IS
THE DEFINITION OF "NICE."
SHE'S THAT SWEET OF A PERSON.
April: OKAY, GUYS,
I'LL SET MY ALARM,
'CAUSE I HAVE MY OWN ALARM,
AND I'LL GO AROUND AND SQUEEZE
ALL YOUR LITTLE TOES,
AND WE'LL ALL BE UP, OKAY?
Sara: WE NEED SLEEP.
Catie: ALL RIGHT, LET'S GO.
Camille: CAN I HAVE MY COAT,
PLEASE?
♪♪♪
(alarm clock buzzing)
Heather: WE KNOW WE'RE GOING
ON A PHOTO SHOOT,
AND THAT'S ALL WE KNEW.
Bethany: WE ALL HAD
30 MINUTES TO GET DONE.
WE ALL HAVE TO GET
IN THE SHOWER.
WE ALL HAVE TO DO OUR HAIR.
WE'RE ALL JUST GOING QUICK,
QUICK, QUICK, QUICK, QUICK.
WE HAVE TO GET GOING,
AND NOBODY'S REALLY PAYING
ATTENTION TO WHO'S HERE
AND WHO'S NOT.
♪♪♪
April: WHERE'S JENASCIA?
April: IF I RUN UPSTAIRS,
ARE YOU GUYS GONNA MAKE SURE
THEY DON'T LEAVE WITHOUT ME,
OR NO?
PROBABLY NOT, RIGHT?
Anna: RUN UP INSIDE AND SEE.
April: WHEN I REALIZED
THAT JENASCIA IS NOT WITH US,
I AM NOT ABLE TO HELP HER OUT
AND GET HER IN THAT VAN
WITHOUT JEOPARDIZING
EVERY SINGLE OTHER PERSON'S
ABILITY TO GET TO THE SHOOT.
SHE HELPED ME OUT ON THE RUNWAY,
AND THAT'S TEARING ME UP INSIDE.
Mercedes: BASICALLY,
IT'S SURVIVAL OF THE FITTEST.
JENASCIA DIDN'T WAKE UP.
THAT'S HER OWN DAMN FAULT,
AND WE CAN'T BABYSIT
EVERYBODY ELSE.
Yoanna: WE'RE ON OUR WAY
TO THE FIRST PHOTO SHOOT EVER,
AND WE DON'T KNOW
WHAT TO EXPECT,
AND JENASCIA DIDN'T MAKE IT
BECAUSE SHE DIDN'T WAKE UP.
Nigel: COME IN. COME IN.
WELCOME TO
INDUSTRIA STUDIOS.
I'M NIGEL BARKER.
I'M GONNA BE YOUR PHOTOGRAPHER
FOR YOUR FIRST FASHION SHOOT
FOR "AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL."
TODAY WE'RE GONNA DO AN AD FOR
FRESHLOOK COLOR CONTACT LENSES.
THE THEME FOR TODAY'S SHOOT
IS THE GARDEN OF EDEN.
IT'S GONNA BE REALLY BEAUTIFUL.
EACH ONE OF YOU HAS HAD
A COMPLETE OUTFIT
DESIGNED FOR YOU BY BODY CAST.
Ed: WHAT WE'RE GONNA DO
TODAY IS WE'RE GONNA
TRANSFORM YOU INTO A VISION
OF ORIGINAL BEAUTY--
EVE IN THE GARDEN OF EDEN.
AND THIS IS THE MAJOR PART
OF YOUR COSTUME RIGHT HERE.
YOUR BODY'S GONNA BE COVERED
IN JEWELS AND BODY PAINT.
DOES ANYBODY HAVE
ANY QUESTIONS ABOUT THE PROCESS
OR WHAT'S GONNA HAPPEN TODAY?
Anna: SO OUR WHOLE BODY'S
GONNA BE COVERED IN THE PAINT?
Nigel: YEAH.
Ed: YOUR BODIES WILL BE
COVERED IN PAINT, YES.
Nigel: BUT OBVIOUSLY,
YOU ARE GONNA BE NUDE,
BUT YOU ARE GONNA BE COVERED
FROM HEAD TO TOE.
IT'S INCREDIBLY INTRICATE.
Xiomara: NUDITY'S GREAT.
I'M ALL ABOUT IT. BRING IT ON.
Anna: I DIDN'T APPRECIATE
THAT.
YOU KNOW, IT'S JUST NOT BEING
LADYLIKE, AND YOU KNOW,
I DO FEEL THAT I REPRESENT
THE MOMS AND THE WIVES
OF THE U.S.,
I GUESS LIKE A ROLE MODEL,
AND I DO ACCEPT
THAT RESPONSIBILITY.
Nigel: I SEE WE ONLY HAVE 11.
WHAT'S THAT ABOUT?
April: JENASCIA'S NOT THERE,
AND I NOTICED THAT HER COSTUME
IS PROBABLY THE MOST ELABORATE
ONE OF ALL OF THEM,
AND THAT REALLY HITS ME HARD,
BECAUSE IT MAKES IT
EVEN MORE APPARENT
THAT SHE'S NOT THERE.
Nigel: WE'LL HAVE TO GET
A WAKE-UP CALL IN TO HER.
Heather: JENASCIA
NOT MAKING IT TO THE PHOTO SHOOT
FOR THE--YOU KNOW,
THIS IS WHAT WE'RE HERE FOR.
IF YOU'RE NOT REALLY THERE FOR
THE MODELING AND FOR THE SHOOT,
THEN YOU'RE GONNA BE... OUT.
(telephone rings)
(ring)
Sara: I DIDN'T SHAKE HER.
Jim: DID ANYONE TOUCH HER?
Sara: NO. I DON'T KNOW.
I WAS, LIKE, THE SECOND ONE
IN THE HOUSE TO WAKE UP.
Jim: WELL, YOU GUYS
ARE HER ROOMMATES.
Sara: SO?
JENASCIA, I LOVE YOU,
BUT I FEEL LIKE SHE NEEDS TO
TAKE ACCOUNTABILITY FOR THAT.
I DON'T FEEL LIKE
I HAVE TO JUSTIFY MYSELF.
Bethany: I DIDN'T KNOW
I HAD TO PLAY MOM TODAY.
SOMEBODY SHOULD HAVE TOLD ME.
Jim: WHEN YOU GUYS TRIED
TO WAKE UP JENASCIA,
WHAT HAPPENED?
Shandi: SHE DIDN'T WAKE UP.
Jim: SHE WAS BREATHING?
Shandi: YEAH.
(telephone rings)
(ring)
Jenascia: Hello?
Jim: IS THIS JENASCIA?
Jenascia: I DON'T KNOW
WHAT THE HELL JUST HAPPENED.
I THOUGHT I WOULD HEAR
THEIR ALARM CLOCK,
OR AT LEAST THEM.
OR MAYBE SOMEONE WOULD
WAKE ME UP, BUT I DON'T KNOW
HOW THIS HAPPENED.
Jim: JUST GET YOURSELF
TOGETHER AND GET HERE A.S.A.P.
Jenascia: (bleep) BITCHES.
♪♪♪
Bethany: YEAH,
I'VE NEVER BEEN BLUE.
I FEEL LIKE A SMURF.
Sara: CHAINS ON NAKED BODY.
I HAVEN'T DONE THAT BEFORE.
♪♪♪
Jenascia: I KNOW
IT'S NEW YORK TRAFFIC,
BUT I'LL PAY YOU DOUBLE
IF YOU CAN GET THERE FAST.
Nigel: OKAY, LADIES.
NOW IT'S SHOW TIME.
EVERY EVE MUST
HAVE AN ADAM.
LET ME BRING IN THE ADAMS.
Heather: THE MALE MODELS--
THE ADAMS--THEY ARE
REALLY, REALLY GOOD-LOOKING.
Nigel: ALL RIGHT, GUYS.
Sara: ADAM WAS RIGHT THERE,
YOU KNOW, WITH EVERYTHING
HANGING OUT.
(chuckles)
Nigel: SARA--
SHE WAS A LITTLE SCARED.
BUT I MEAN, I'D LIKE TO
SEE MORE FROM HER.
MOVE YOUR BODY AROUND
SO I SEE THAT SIDE
OF YOUR BODY REALLY NICE.
THERE YOU GO.
BETHANY NEEDS TO WORK
ON HER MOVEMENT.
BUT YOU KNOW WHAT?
WHEN WE HAVE AN INCREDIBLE
GARDEN OF EDEN,
AND WE NEEDED SOMEONE WITH
SOME EXHIBITIONIST QUALITIES.
SHE CERTAINLY HAD THEM.
THAT'S NICE.
♪♪♪
Jenascia: HELLO?
Nigel: APRIL, OUR ASIAN EVE,
WAS GORGEOUS.
HER BODY IS FANTASTIC.
HER FACE IS FANTASTIC.
MY GOODNESS ME.
THAT'S EXACTLY WHAT
I'M LOOKING FOR.
Nigel: NIGEL.
Jenascia: NICE TO MEET YOU.
Nigel: YOU'RE A LITTLE LATE.
IT'S OKAY. IT'S ALL RIGHT.
IT'S OKAY. YEAH. COME HERE.
COME HERE.
Jenascia: OH, MY GOD.
THIS IS NOT REALLY HAPPENING.
I WAS SO NAIVE TO THINK
THAT THE OTHER GIRLS WERE
ACTUALLY GONNA HELP ME OUT,
EVEN THOUGH I HAD HELPED
SOME OF THEM OUT.
YOU KNOW, LIKE WITH APRIL--
I HELPED HER.
I... HELPED HER SO MUCH
ON THAT FIRST FASHION SHOW.
SHE SHOULD BE KISSING
THE... GROUND THAT I WALK ON
RIGHT NOW.
I'LL BE FINE.
Nigel: IT'S OKAY, THOUGH.
IT REALLY--
WE'RE GONNA DEAL WITH IT.
Jenascia: I'M MORE MAD
THAN ANYTHING.
Nigel: I KNOW,
BUT YOU NEED TO LET THAT GO.
BOTTOM LINE IS YOU MADE IT.
RIGHT NOW WHAT WOULD BE MORE
OF A PROBLEM FOR ME IS NOT
THE FACT THAT YOU'RE LATE.
THE BIG PROBLEM RIGHT NOW
IS THAT YOU'RE UPSET.
Jenascia: THE WATERWORKS.
Nigel: YOU WANT TO SORT OF
SAY, "DAMN IT, YOU WERE LATE,
YOU KNOW? WHAT IS THIS?"
BUT I CAN'T.
WE HAVE TO KEEP ALL THAT IN.
I HAVE TO CAPTURE A SHOT.
Jenascia: BITCHES!
Nigel: WE HAVE A LONG DAY
AHEAD OF US,
AND WE HAVE OTHER THINGS TO DO
OTHER THAN TAKE CARE
OF ONE GIRL.
♪♪♪
Nigel: TWIST YOUR LEG AROUND
A BIT.
SWING THE OTHER WAY.
Nigel: BEAUTIFUL.
Catie: I GOT
THE HEAVENLY EVE,
WHICH WAS BASICALLY A PAINTING
OF, LIKE, THE SISTINE CHAPEL--
THE CEILING OF IT--ON ME.
Nigel: CATIE--
I THOUGHT FOR A MOMENT
SHE WAS GONNA BE A FAINTER,
SHE WAS LIKE... ON THE CAMERA.
CHIN UP. EYES UP HIGH.
Anna: I SAT THERE
IN THE ROOM AND I SAW
THESE GIRLS--
THEIR COOCHIE WAS SHOWIN',
THEIR BREASTS WERE HANGIN' OUT,
AND NIPPLES SHOWIN',
AND PLUS THE MALE MODEL
IS DOWN THERE, YOU KNOW,
WHERE YOUR PRIVATE PARTY IS.
Man: IT'S JUST A DOT
RIGHT HERE.
Anna: I DON'T WANNA BE
A PART OF THAT.
I CAN'T JUST IMAGINE
SOMEONE ELSE HERE AND DOWN THERE
EXCEPT MY HUSBAND, YOU KNOW?
AND IF I SHOW IT
TO THE WHOLE WORLD, YOU KNOW,
WHAT'S SO SPECIAL WHEN I...
(crying)
I JUST CAN'T--I CAN'T DO IT.
I'M VERY UNCOMFORTABLE.
I CANNOT DO IT, YOU KNOW?
I HAVE TO...
YOU KNOW,
THIS IS FOR MY HUSBAND.
I CAN'T SHOW NO ONE ELSE.
Yohanca: RIGHT.
Anna: I'M NOT GONNA DO IT.
Catie: ANNA--YOU KNOW,
SHE'S IN A DIFFERENT PLACE
IN HER LIFE.
SHE HAS A SON
AND SHE HAS A HUSBAND.
DO YOU RETOUCH SO NONE OF
THE NIPPLES SHOW AND THAT STUFF?
Nigel: THINGS LIKE THAT,
YEAH.
THEY'RE NOT GONNA BE SHOWING.
WE CAN'T DO THAT.
AND THIS
IS AN IMPORTANT THING.
IT'D BE A REAL SHAME
FOR YOU NOT TO BE
PARTICIPATING IN IT,
AND WE'LL MARCH YOU UP
TO THE SET,
HIDE YOU WITH A GOWN,
DO WHATEVER WE NEED TO DO.
Anna: AND IT'S GONNA BE
THE SAME ANSWER, SO...
Nigel: OKAY.
WELL, THAT BEING SAID, THEN,
I'M SORRY, BUT I'M GONNA HAVE
TO ASK YOU TO LEAVE.
I'M SORRY.
Anna: AND HE THOUGHT THAT
IF I DIDN'T WANNA BE A PART
OF IT, THEN YOU KNOW,
I SHOULDN'T BE IN HIS PRESENCE
WHATSOEVER.
Nigel: YOU KNOW WHAT?
AT THIS POINT,
I JUST NEEDED A GIRL,
BECAUSE WE HAVEN'T GOT TIME,
AND IT'S A REAL SHAME
SHE WASN'T COMFORTABLE BEING
NUDE UNDER HER MAKEUP.
Heather: I DON'T MIND
A REALLY HOT PHOTOGRAPHER
LOOKING AT MY NAKED BODY.
Nigel: HEATHER,
FIX YOUR EYES.
BUT ACTUALLY FOR ME,
HER LOOK IS VERY CALIFORNIA.
EYES UP HIGHER.
MERCEDES--WHEN I WOULD
GIVE HER DIRECTION,
SHE WOULD REMEMBER FOR MAYBE
ONLY ONE OR TWO FRAMES,
AND SHE WOULD SLIP BACK
INTO WHAT SHE WAS DOING BEFORE.
EYES UP OVER HERE. THERE.
SHANDI NEEDS TO REALIZE
THAT SHE'S A BEAUTIFUL GIRL.
FOR MODELING, YOU REALLY NEED
TO BE AWARE OF YOURSELF.
THAT'S SOMETHING
THAT WILL COME IN TIME.
YOANNA--HER FACE IS FANTASTIC,
BUT, YOU KNOW, HER BODY--
COULD DO A LITTLE BIT OF WORK.
Man: MALE AND FEMALE.
Jenascia: I WAS A LITTLE BIT
TEARY, LIKE, ALL DAY,
AND ALL I COULD THINK WAS,
"THOSE BITCHES."
Nigel: CHIN UP FOR ME,
SWEETIE.
THERE YOU GO.
HOLD THE ARROW OF THE BOW DOWN.
TWIST IT UP A LITTLE BIT.
THE TOP PART OF THE BOW'S
A LITTLE HIGHER.
PUT YOUR HAND ON YOUR HIP
FOR ME.
YOU'VE GOT A BEAUTIFUL BODY.
PLAY WITH IT.
REAL ATTITUDY. BOOM.
Xiomara: JENASCIA'S
NOT REALLY GETTING IT.
NIGEL KEEPS ON TELLING HER,
"NO, DO THIS. LOOK THAT WAY.
LOOK THAT WAY."
YOU DON'T WANT A PHOTOGRAPHER
TO HAVE TO DIRECT YOU,
BECAUSE THAT'S WHY
YOU'RE A MODEL.
Nigel: NO, IT'S NOT--
NOT SO MUCH.
JENASCIA BLEW IT
BEING LATE THIS MORNING.
SHE REALLY DIDN'T
FULLY GET INTO IT,
WHICH IS A SHAME.
Jenascia: I DON'T KNOW WHY
THEY DIDN'T WAKE ME UP,
BUT IF THIS DOESN'T
GET ME ELIMINATED, IT'S ON.
IT'S SO (bleep) ON.
I'M NOT PLAYING ANYMORE.
I'M NOT GONNA BE NICE
AND HELP ANYONE ANYMORE.
YOU DON'T HAVE
THE RIGHT CLOTHES ON,
(bleep) YOU.
THIS IS ABOUT ME NOW.
Anna: I SAID NO
TO THE FACT OF POSING NUDE,
AND NIGEL--HE ASKED ME
TO LEAVE THE SET AREA.
I FELT LIKE IT DID NOT
JEOPARDIZED MY CHANCES AT ALL.
Woman: (gasps)
Women: (speaking
over each other)
Anna: TYRA MAIL.
"TOMORROW IS YOUR FIRST MEETING
WITH THE JUDGES.
ONLY 11 OF YOU WILL CONTINUE ON
WITH THE HOPE OF BECOMING
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL.
ONE OF YOU WILL BE ELIMINATED."
♪♪♪
Heather: REALITY HAS HIT ME.
THERE'S AN ELIMINATION.
THIS IS IT.
THIS IS THE BOTTOM LINE.
Shandi: IT'S A WEIRD DAY.
JENASCIA THINKS
SHE'S GOING HOME
BECAUSE SHE DIDN'T WAKE UP
ON TIME,
AND, YOU KNOW, SHE WAS LATE.
Jenascia: MAYBE I WAS
JUST SUPPOSED TO GO THIS FAR.
♪♪♪
Tyra: WOW, MY 12 FINALISTS.
YOU GUYS ARE HERE
IN THE INFAMOUS JUDGING ROOM.
WE HAVE OUR PANEL OF JUDGES.
WE HAVE JANICE DICKINSON.
JANICE WAS ONE
OF THE FIRST SUPERMODELS.
Janice: MY JOB IS TO BE
AS BRUTALLY HONEST AS POSSIBLE,
AND, HEY, LET'S FACE IT.
IF THE GIRLS CAN'T HANDLE
MY CRITIQUE,
THEY SURE ARE NOT GOING
TO BE ABLE TO HANDLE
THE FASHION INDUSTRY.
Tyra: NEXT,
WE HAVE ERIC NICHOLSON.
ERIC IS THE SENIOR FASHION
EDITOR AT "JANE" MAGAZINE.
Eric: WHAT I THINK
MAKES A TOP MODEL
IS SOMEONE WHO ADDS
THAT EXTRA SOMETHING
THAT A PHOTOGRAPHER
WANTS TO CAPTURE.
Tyra: AND LAST BUT NOT LEAST,
I KNOW YOU GUYS DIDN'T KNOW,
NIGEL BARKER IS
OUR PERMANENT JUDGE,
NOT JUST JUDGE FOR TODAY.
Nigel: HI, LADIES.
WHAT I'M ALWAYS LOOKING FOR
IN A MODEL IS A MUSE,
A FACE THAT'S GONNA INSPIRE ME.
Tyra: NOW HERE'S THE PRIZES.
YOU GET A CONTRACT
WITH IMG MODELS,
ONE OF THE TOP
MANAGEMENT COMPANIES
IN THE WORLD,
AND I HAVE BEEN WITH THEM
FOR A NUMBER OF YEARS.
YOU GET A COSMETICS CAMPAIGN
WITH SEPHORA,
THE LEADING BEAUTY RETAILER.
YOU WILL ALSO HAVE A SPREAD
IN "JANE" MAGAZINE,
WHICH IS THE HIPPEST, TRENDIEST
MAGAZINE OUT THERE RIGHT NOW.
NOW THERE'S A COUPLE OF THINGS
THAT YOU GUYS ARE GONNA
BE JUDGED ON.
FIRST, YOU'RE GONNA BE JUDGED ON
WHAT YOU JUST STRAIGHT
WALKED IN HERE WITH.
THAT'S YOUR NATURAL TALENT.
THEN YOU'RE GONNA BE JUDGED
ON YOUR POTENTIAL.
ALSO, YOUR PERSONALITY.
THE FOURTH THING IS
YOUR ABILITY TO BE VERSATILE
IN THE FASHION INDUSTRY.
I'M LOOKING FOR SOMEBODY
THAT'S EDGY AND EDITORIAL
IN HIGH FASHION,
AND I'M LOOKING FOR SOMEONE
THAT CAN SMILE
AND SELL TOOTHPASTE.
AND THE LAST THING
IS YOUR PERFORMANCE
IN YOUR PHOTO SHOOTS.
WE'RE GONNA BRING YOU IN
FOR YOUR INDIVIDUAL EVALUATIONS
ONE BY ONE.
WE'VE RANDOMLY DRAWN NAMES,
AND, XIOMARA, YOU'RE FIRST.
SO HOW DID YOU FEEL
WHEN I TOLD YOU
THAT YOU HAD TO DO
A SURPRISE FASHION SHOW?
Xiomara: I WAS SHOCKED,
COMPLETELY SHOCKED.
Tyra: HERE IT IS.
Nigel: YOUR EYES
WEREN'T CONNECTING.
YOUR WALK WAS GREAT,
BUT THE EYES WEREN'T THERE.
Tyra: YOU ALSO HAD YOUR FIRST
PROFESSIONAL PHOTO SHOOT
WITH THE GARDEN OF EDEN THEME,
AND HERE IS YOUR BEST SHOT.
Xiomara: (gasps)
Nigel: WHAT DO YOU THINK?
Xiomara: I AM SO HOT!
Janice: THIS IS AN AMPUTEE LOOK?
THERE'S NO RIGHT ARM, YOU SEE?
SO IF YOU FANNED AROUND
YOUR UPPER BODY,
YOU WOULD HAVE SHOWN
A LITTLE BIT OF RIGHT ARM.
Tyra: YOUR WALK IS OKAY,
BUT YOU DON'T KNOW WHAT TO DO
WHEN YOU GET TO THE END
OF THE RUNWAY.
April: OH, MY GOD!
Janice: OKAY, FACE--FLAWLESS.
BODY UP TO YOUR RIGHT FOOT,
YOU'RE CUTTING IT OFF
WITH THE FAN,
UNLESS YOU WERE HIDING
THAT YOU DIDN'T SHAVE
YOUR RIGHT LEG OR SOMETHING.
Nigel: I NOTICE THAT
YOUR WALK IS A LITTLE STIFF.
Catie: YEAH,
I HAD THOSE BOOTS,
AND I'VE NEVER WALKED
IN BOOTS LIKE THAT BEFORE.
Eric: I CAN TELL
YOU'RE SLIGHTLY UNCOMFORTABLE.
IT LOOKS LIKE
YOUR LEG IS WOBBLING,
AND LIKE YOU'RE ABOUT
TO FALL OVER AT ANY MINUTE.
Tyra: SO WHAT DID YOU THINK?
Sara: TOO BOUNCY.
Tyra: THE BOUNCE WAS GOOD,
BUT JUST A LITTLE LESS.
IS YOUR FINGER IN HIS MOUTH?
Sara: OH, YEAH,
IT WAS EVERYWHERE.
Tyra: OH, WOW!
Sara: I THINK I WAS THE ONLY EVE
THAT TOUCHED HER ADAM.
Nigel: THE LEG THING'S
A LITTLE UNUSUAL THERE.
Tyra: A LITTLE MARCH.
Yoanna: I DIDN'T THINK
I DID TOO GOOD.
Janice: YOU HAVE
A CLASSIC FACE MADE FOR BEAUTY.
YOU LOOK VERY SOMBER.
NEXT TIME YOU MIGHT WANT
TO LIGHTEN IT UP.
Camille: WOW!
Tyra: THE ONLY THING
THAT I WOULD SAY IS
TO KIND OF STICK YOUR BOOTY OUT
JUST A LITTLE BIT MORE
AND GIVE IT A LITTLE "POW"!
HI, ANNA.
Anna: HELLO.
Tyra: HOW DO YOU FEEL ABOUT
BEING
THE ONLY PLUS-SIZE MODEL HERE?
Anna: I'M SURE OF MYSELF,
AND, YOU KNOW, THAT'S WHO I AM,
SO THAT'S FINE.
Tyra: IT LOOKED LIKE
YOU WERE MORE OF A BEAUTY QUEEN
THAN A MODEL.
Janice: RIGHT.
Eric: ABSOLUTELY.
Tyra: IT LOOKED LIKE
YOU WERE LIKE, "HI, HI."
Eric: MISS GEORGIA PEACH.
I ACTUALLY THOUGHT
THE LITTLE HEAD BOB AT THE END
SEEMED CONTRIVED.
Tyra: WE DON'T HAVE A PICTURE
FOR YOU, AND WHY IS THAT?
Anna: I JUST FELT LIKE
I COULD NOT DO IT.
IT WAS NOT LADYLIKE TO ME.
Nigel: NOT LADYLIKE?
WHAT DOES THAT MEAN?
Janice: HMM. I GET IT.
IT'S YOUR RELIGION.
Anna: IT'S NOT
SO MUCH RELIGION.
I'M JUST, YOU KNOW,
TRYING TO BE CHRISTLIKE.
Mercedes: I GIVE THAT A 10.
Nigel: YOU'VE GOT
THE CONFIDENCE.
YOU'VE GOT THE ATTITUDE.
NOW REFINE IT.
TONE IT DOWN A BIT.
Janice: YOU HAVE
A GREAT POSE, A GREAT STANCE,
AND YOUR FACE IS KNOCKOUT.
Tyra: WELL DONE.
Nigel: WELL DONE.
Tyra: THERE'S A LOT GOING ON,
YOU KNOW, OVER THE SHOULDER
AND STUFF.
Heather: I NOTICED THAT, TOO.
Tyra: YEAH.
Nigel: WHAT DO YOU THINK?
Heather: I, I...
I'M SPEECHLESS.
I ABSOLUTELY LOVE IT.
Tyra: I THINK
YOUR BODY IS GORGEOUS.
YOU HAVE GREAT MUSCLE TONE.
AND YOU'RE ACTUALLY
BORDERLINE PLUS SIZE,
SO YOU MAY WANT TO GAIN
A LITTLE WEIGHT OR LOSE SOME.
I THINK PLUS SIZE
IS ABSOLUTELY GORGEOUS.
Janice: LOOK UP,
LOOK UP, LOOK UP.
LOOK UP!
NEXT TIME YOU HAVE
TO LOOK STRAIGHT OUT
AND HOLD YOUR HEAD UP,
BUT YOU PRACTICE
WITH A PHONE BOOK
LIKE AUDREY HEPBURN.
Tyra: WHAT ARE YOU THINKING?
Shandi: OH, MY GOODNESS!
Tyra: SHANDI,
DID YOU EVER THINK
YOU COULD LOOK THAT BEAUTIFUL?
Shandi: OH, MY GOODNESS!
LOOK AT MY BUTT.
I HAVE A BUTT!
Nigel: IN THIS PICTURE
YOU ARE OUTSTANDING,
HOWEVER, YOUR DRESS--
IT REALLY DOESN'T SAY MUCH.
Janice: COLLEGE STUDENT,
IT SAYS,
INSTEAD OF, LIKE,
HOPEFUL MODEL WANNABE.
Janice: I THINK THE WALK
NEEDS A LOT OF WORK.
IT WAS TOO STACCATO FOR ME.
Bethany: INTERESTING!
Janice: CHER,
EAT YOUR HEART OUT!
Bethany: I HAD A LOT
TO WORK WITH THERE!
Eric: I'M NOT SO SURE
ABOUT THE BOOBS.
Tyra: YOUR BODY TYPE
IS VERY SEXY.
YOU HAVE TO BE VERY CONSCIOUS
OF HOW YOU POSE,
'CAUSE IT'LL TAKE YOU
AWAY FROM FASHION
AND INTO MORE OF THAT KIND
OF GIRLIE MAG TYPE OF THING.
Jenascia: HI.
Tyra: HI, JENASCIA.
Nigel: HI THERE.
HOW ARE YOU DOING?
Jenascia: I'M GOOD.
Janice: WORK IT.
YOU VOGUED!
Tyra: I THOUGHT
THAT YOU KIND OF MOVED
A LITTLE BIT TOO MUCH.
JUST KIND OF HIT IT ONCE,
INSTEAD OF, "UNH-UNH-UNH-UNH."
Nigel: ON THE ACTUAL SHOOT
YOU REALLY DIDN'T
OFFER ANYTHING SOFT.
YOU WERE MEANT TO BE EVE.
IT WOULD BE NICE
TO SEE JUST A LITTLE BIT
MORE GENTLENESS IN YOU.
YOU KNOW WHAT I'M GOING TO
TALK ABOUT THOUGH, DON'T YOU?
YOU, YOUNG LADY,
WERE LATE FOR MY SHOOT.
Janice: WHAT?
Nigel: YOU DIDN'T SHOW UP
UNTIL I THINK--
WAS IT TWO HOURS?
Jenascia: IT MIGHT
HAVE BEEN THREE.
Eric: YOU'RE WASTING
OTHER PEOPLE'S MONEY.
Jenascia: YEAH.
Janice: 5'7" IS
A LITTLE SHORT TO BE A MODEL,
SO WE HAVE TO COMPENSATE
WITH PUNCTUALITY.
Tyra: TIME IS MONEY.
Jenascia: THANK YOU.
Tyra: ALL RIGHT,
NOW IT'S TIME TO VOTE.
WE HAVE TO DECIDE
WHO IS GOING HOME.
FIRST, WE HAVE APRIL.
Nigel: SHE'S GOT A LOT OF SEX
APPEAL IN A SUBTLE WAY.
Janice: I'D LIKE
TO SEE HER STAY IN.
Tyra: HEATHER.
Eric: SHE DEFINITELY
HAS POTENTIAL
IN FRONT OF THE CAMERA FOR SURE.
Tyra: SARA.
Janice: I'M NOT CRAZY
ABOUT HER.
Nigel: SHE ACTUALLY
COULD MOVE.
SHE CAN SMILE.
Tyra: CAMILLE.
Janice: CAMILLE ROCKS.
Eric: MAYBE SHE'S
A LITTLE BIT TOO COCKY.
MAYBE SHE BELIEVES IN THIS
A LITTLE BIT TOO MUCH.
Tyra: MERCEDES.
Janice: MERCEDES
IS MY FAVORITE.
Tyra: MERCEDES
IS A BEAUTIFUL GIRL,
BUT SHE MIGHT BE
A LITTLE BIT TOO COMMERCIAL.
Nigel: I THINK YOANNA
IS AMAZING.
HER BODY NEEDS A BIT OF WORK.
Janice: BUT HER FACE
IS PERFECTION.
Tyra: JENASCIA.
Nigel: JENASCIA
WAS LATE ON MY SET,
WHICH IS NEVER A GOOD THING.
Eric: 5'7"?
Janice: SHORT!
SHE'S TOO SHORT. LET'S FACE IT.
COUTURE IS TALL, THIN.
Tyra: I LOVE THE FACT
THAT SHE'S SHORT.
I LIKE DIFFERENT.
I LIKE PLUS SIZE.
I LIKE SHORT,
BUT LATE I HATE, SO...
Janice: THERE YOU GO.
Tyra: CATIE.
Janice: I LIKE CATIE.
I'D LIKE TO SEE HER STAY.
Tyra: XIOMARA.
Eric: I THINK SHE DOES
LOOK GREAT IN THE PHOTOGRAPH.
MAYBE, LIKE, SHE HAS TOO MANY
TEETH IN HER MOUTH, THOUGH.
Tyra: TEETH CAN BE FIXED.
IN?
Eric: I'M NOT SO SURE
ABOUT BETHANY.
I PERSONALLY HAVE A PROBLEM
WITH THE BOOBS.
Janice: WHY?
Eric: I DON'T KNOW.
IT'S TOO, UH, CHA-CHA-CHA.
Nigel: SHE DOES LOOK
LIKE A DR. SEUSS CHARACTER.
Janice: BETHANY
IS BOB MACKIE ON CRACK.
I STILL LOVE HER.
Nigel: SHANDI
IS VERY UNUSUAL.
Janice: I THINK SHE'S HIDING.
I BET IF WE SMACKED A RED DRESS
ON HER AND SOME STILETTOS,
WE COULD TURN HER OUT,
WE COULD HELP HER.
Eric: THERE'S
A BEAUTIFUL GIRL THERE.
NOT EVERYBODY
CAN SEE THAT, THOUGH.
Tyra: LET'S DISCUSS ANNA.
I LOVE A PLUS-SIZE GIRL.
SHE HAS A BEAUTIFUL
PLUS-SIZE FIGURE.
Eric: HER RUNWAY
DEFINITELY NEEDED SOME WORK.
Janice: HER REFUSAL
TO DO THE SESSION
DIDN'T WORK FOR ME.
Tyra: JUST BECAUSE
SHE DID NOT DO THE SHOOT,
DOESN'T MEAN THAT
SHE'S AUTOMATICALLY ELIMINATED.
Eric: WHEN SHE WAS IN FRONT
OF ME, THAT ATTITUDE...
Nigel: THAT WAS
THE PROBLEM FOR ME--
THE ATTITUDE ABOUT IT.
Eric: SHE DIDN'T EVEN KNOW
WHAT HER ARGUMENT WAS
ABOUT WHY SHE DIDN'T DO IT.
SHE SORT OF, LIKE,
HAD HALF AN IDEA.
Nigel: HOWEVER,
NORMALLY, YOU KNOW, YOU WOULD
WARN A GIRL IN ADVANCE,
SO SHE WASN'T WARNED.
IN FACT, THE GIRL THAT WAS LATE
WAS MORE DAMAGING FOR ME.
Janice: OH!
Tyra: ALL RIGHT.
THE JUDGES HAVE REACHED
A DECISION.
Tyra: ALL RIGHT, LADIES,
IN MY HANDS I HAVE 11 PHOTOS,
AND THESE PHOTOS REPRESENT
THE 11 GIRLS THAT WILL CONTINUE
ON THE JOURNEY TOWARDS BECOMING
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL.
CAMILLE.
CONGRATULATIONS.
YOU'RE STILL IN THE RUNNING
TOWARDS BECOMING
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL.
SHANDI.
CONGRATULATIONS, SHANDI.
APRIL.
MERCEDES.
CATIE.
SARA.
CONGRATULATIONS, SARA.
HEATHER.
CONGRATULATIONS.
YOANNA.
BETHANY.
Tyra: CONGRATULATIONS.
XIOMARA.
CONGRATULATIONS.
YOU'RE STILL IN THE RUNNING
TOWARDS BECOMING
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL.
Xiomara: THANK YOU.
Tyra: WILL JENASCIA AND ANNA
PLEASE STEP FORWARD?
Tyra: ANNA, THE JUDGES
WERE QUITE DISAPPOINTED
THAT YOU DIDN'T DO
THE PHOTO SHOOT,
BUT YOU'VE GOT
A CERTAIN RESPONSIBILITY
AS A WIFE AND A MOM,
AND WE RESPECT THAT.
JENASCIA, DO YOU KNOW
WHAT I'M GONNA TELL YOU?
Jenascia: THAT I WAS LATE.
Tyra: YOU HAVE
TO DEPEND ON YOURSELF,
'CAUSE THOSE GIRLS COULD HAVE
EASILY JUST SHOOK YOU AWAKE
AND SAID, "COME ON."
BUT EVERYBODY'S LOOKING OUT
FOR THEMSELVES.
THIS ISN'T A SORORITY.
THIS IS A MODELING COMPETITION.
WHOEVER'S NAME I DO NOT CALL
MUST IMMEDIATELY
RETURN TO THE LOFT,
PACK YOUR BELONGINGS AND LEAVE.
Tyra: JENASCIA,
CONGRATULATIONS.
YOU'RE STILL IN THE RUNNING
TOWARDS BECOMING
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL,
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP
ON-TIME MODEL.
THANK YOU, ANNA.
Anna: THANK YOU, TYRA.
Xiomara: BYE, MOMMY.
Anna: I DO NOT REGRET
ANY DECISIONS THAT I MADE HERE
AT ALL.
I GOT KNOCKED OUT
AND KNOCKED DOWN.
IT HURT FOR A FEW MOMENTS,
BUT I'M STRONGER NOW,
AND, YOU KNOW, I CAN GET BACK UP
AND STILL KEEP GOING.
I'M EXCITED TO GO BACK
AND SEE MY SON AND MY HUSBAND.
Tyra: STAY TUNED FOR SCENES
FROM OUR NEXT EPISODE.
HERE'S WHAT'S COMING UP
ON "AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL."
YOANNA AND CAMILLE FACE OFF...
Camille: IF I HAVE SOMETHING
TO SAY TO YOU,
I WILL SAY IT TO YOUR FACE.
Jenascia: THERE'S GONNA BE
A LOT OF DRAMA IN THE HOUSE.
Tyra: WHILE SHANDI
CAN'T QUITE WALK THE WALK.
J.: HELP.
Tyra: AND A FIERY
HOUSE MEETING GETS UGLY.
Yoanna: JUST--
I'M NOT FINISHED!
YOU SHUT UP.